et on prend qui tue le chemin de saint
dié sur loire dans le loir et cher pour
fêter les 20 ans du val de loire inscrit
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco et on
vous retrouve sur place rebecca bonsoir
benoît bonsoir à toutes et à tous
et oui bienvenue à la maison de la loire
de saint-dié vous l'avez dit on célèbre
ce soir l'inscription du val de loire au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco c'était
le 30 novembre 2000 il y a vingt ans
bonsoir bruno m'a remis rolly
souhaiterait directeur de la mission val
de loire qu'est ce que ça vous fait de
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui ce label
prestigieux de l'unesco ça fait 20 ans
que le val de loire le possède
ça me fait plaisir ça fait très plaisir
et j'espère que c'est un plaisir partagé
par les habitants et tous ceux qui
viennent alors ici on se trouve à la
maison de la loire en quoi ce lieu est
symbolique pour le val de loire
alors c'est ici et ici et dans les
autres maisons de la loire
qu'effectivement on peut avoir
finalement une bonne approche de ce que
c'est que le val de loire à la fois son
patrimoine mais aussi ses milieux ces
écosystèmes donc une immersion c'est
presque la porte d'entrée dans le val de
loire ça pourrait être effectivement les
maisons de la loire alors le classement
à l'unesco est assez rare dans la région
il ya seulement trois sites qui sont
classés inscrits plutôt au patrimoine
mondial la cathédrale de chartres la
cathédrale de bourges la collégiale de
neuville st cyp hull kr et dernièrement
donc le val de loire
sur quels critères exactement alors
trois critères essentiellement donc
s'est inscrit au titre des paysages
culturels c'est un peu différent de
sites qui vous est mentionnée et ces
trois critères que l'on tout le monde
connaît un peu l'intensité patrimoniale
la qualité du patrimoine présent les
illustrations de deux périodes
historiques la renaissance et le siècle
des lumières la renaissance on voit
pourquoi on est aux portes de chambord
ça parle un peu et puis un troisième
critère qui est très important et que
les maisons de la loire illustre bien
c'est la qualité des relations entre les
communautés humaines et le fleuve facile
d'obtenir ce label notamment en raison
des quatre centrales nucléaires qui
borde la loire belleville dampierre
saint laurent et chinon alors
effectivement il ya eu un petit
ajournement d'un an il a fallu un an de
plus pour franchir le pas et puis
véritablement rentrer dans cette sauce
dans cette cour très très prisé merci en
tout cas ce label le val de loire et
venu ces vingt dernières années un
moteur important de notre économie
régionale mais vous le savez le tourisme
est aujourd'hui touchée de plein fouet
par la crise sanitaire avec des sites
fermés une clientèle qui se fait rare
cette année 2020 c'est donc un
anniversaire très particulier car le
choc a été rude aussi pour le val de
loire ont fait le point avec nathanaël
le maire et on se retrouve juste après
au printemps 2020 quand démarre la
saison touristique en centre val de
loire
le confinement 1 a stoppé net la
fréquentation des touristes
l'interdiction des voyages en groupe et
la fermeture des frontières ont placé
nos grands châteaux dans une situation
intenable économiquement amboise
chambord ou chenonceau ont eu un
printemps catastrophique
il faudra attendre les vacances de
juillet août et même la toussaint pour
voir la clientèle française affluent et
enfin en centre val de loire
une redécouverte des français de leurs
territoires qui ne compensera pas les
pertes d'exploitation causée par la
crise du coc vite 19 2 mars 2020 à fin
août les professionnels du tourisme de
la région déclarent une baisse de 50% de
leur chiffre d'affaires pour l'ensemble
des grands sites
la fréquentation est en baisse de 20%
durant l'été en lien avec le respect
intrasèque des mesures sanitaires la
pratique du vélo a connu un regain
incroyable aussi bien grâce aux locaux
qu'aux visiteurs la loire à vélo a
poursuivi sa hausse de fréquentation
avec 24% de passage en plus par rapport
à l'an dernier
un tourisme dans les jardins de la
france par temps de crise qui a
plébiscité les petites structures
d'hébergements locatifs dont le loiret
les gîtes de france ont vu leur
fréquentation en juillet août augmenté
de 20% et au final la baisse sur l'année
sera de -6%
malgré le confinement les grands
perdants de la saison touristique à
l'heure des bilans
ce sera bien sûr l'hôtellerie et la
restauration d'ores et déjà en plus du
fonds national de solidarité pour les
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
la région centre val de loire a créé le
kobe de 19 ans renaissance afin d'
avance remboursable pour la trésorerie
et des petits investissements
reste à savoir à quel horizon aura lieu
cette renaissance du tourisme
et nous sommes toujours à la maison de
la loire bruno marc me relis le label
val de loire at il selon vous permis un
autre territoire de mieux résister à la
crise du tourisme cette année en 2020
oui certainement certainement les
chiffres on l'a vu d'ailleurs dès que
dès que nous avons été tous des cons
fille née il ya eu un vrai appétit pour
les paysages pour un retour au fleuve
qui étaient déjà présents et 20 ans que
c'est un travail acharné mais là on a
bien vu que à la fois et les habitants
là la nouveauté c'est que les habitants
ont retrouvé un peu le lien un peu
viscéral avec leur fleuve et on a vu
notamment le beau succès de la loire à
vélo alors la loire à vélo c'est
l'incarnation un peu idéale du lien
entre nature et culture et tourisme
est-ce qu'on peut évaluer le bénéfice
économique de ce label de l'unesco pour
le val de loire
on doit pouvoir nous ne l'avons pas fait
non mais c'est très compliqué parce que
ça à faire entrer énormément de facteurs
qu'il faudrait analyser on peut estimer
que de toute façon c'est un c'est un
vrai bénéficié il ya quand même quelques
chiffres du crt que je peux vous donner
qui étaient des cif de 2019
20% des tours étranges et mentionne le
label comme une des raisons et 10 % des
touristes nationaux donc on voit que ça
a quand même une forte de loire valley
effectivement en anglais alors ce
classement sert aussi à préserver
l'environnement du territoire notamment
par la maîtrise de l'urbanisme
est-ce que c'est contraignant c'est
contraignant parce que évidemment on
peut pas se développer comme on le
ferait n'importe où puisque on le dit
c'est un territoire singulier reconnu
par la communauté internationale donc
oui on peut pas y faire n'importe quoi
mais c'est à nous tous de relever le
défi c'est pas simplement à l'état
régalien de d'imposer effectivement
concrètement comment ça se passe pour
conserver ce label est ce que l'unesco
fait des contrôles périodiques alors
l'unesco demande à l'état effectivement
garant donc du label de faire des
évaluations périodiques du plan de
gestion
donc oui il y en a effectivement donc le
prochain c'est pour bientôt et on est
dedans on commence là effectivement une
évaluation donc avec des critères que
vous avez mentionné de l'étalement
urbain artificialisation des sols de
qualité des paysages
merci beaucoup bruno marc me relis nous
avoir accueillis ici à la maison de la
loire alors parmi les éléments qui
participent au patrimoine culturel
ligériens il ya les bateaux et ceux qui
perpétuent la tradition rencontre avec
un jeune homme qui a décidé de créer son
entreprise de promenade
bateau sur la loire pour faire
fonctionner son affaire il compte
évidemment sur l'engouement du public et
sur la construction d'un bateau en bois
traditionnels regarder patrimoine vivant
de la culture ligérienne le constructeur
de bateaux max panier est lui-même le
successeur de la maison brémard de saint
germain surviennent tout fut trop et
gabart sont toujours d'actualité dans
son atelier à ciel ouvert c'est la corée
bien sûr pas à commander son bateau de
12 mètres
à 34 ans il se lance dans la création
d'entreprises touristiques avec des
balades sur le fleuve royal
par rapport à mon expérience quoi j'ai
déjà petite quinzaine d'années
d'expérience de navigation sur le fleuve
et c'est vrai que
ben on est très souvent demandé quoi il
ya beaucoup de gens dans les gens du
coin les gens du coin se ré approprier
le fleuve et les professionnels du
tourisme valorise extrêmement bien la
destination loire donc c'est vrai qu'on
est là pour pour nous emmener les gens
sur le fleuve donc donc autant voilà
prendre un petit peu son envol et
pouvoir les emmener sur mon bateau avec
le renouveau de la batellerie max panier
a vu ses commandes évoluer des bateaux
de pêche traditionnelle il est passé aux
bateaux de loisirs
la toule c'était des to cabane est fait
pour fait pour la pêche la pêche la
pêche aux barrages l'agent a été
transformé en bateau de tourisme et en
bateau cantine tout à cabannes et les
gens ils couchent dessus et je promène
elle lui lui vaut rien il veut juste une
toux à passagers entre aurélien et max
ce n'est pas juste deux générations deux
ligériens qui se croisent c'est aussi un
patrimoine qui s'adapte à la modernité
déjà max panier parce que historiquement
quoi c'est quelqu'un qui sont le long de
la loire est connu par le biais de ses
diverses constructions
moi j'ai eu la chance de naviguer sur
des constructions qu'ils avaient réalisé
aussi là où je travaillais avant et puis
ils ont une gueule quoi ces bateaux ils
ont vraiment une gueule ils sont rasées
et puis c'est un monsieur qui a plein de
conseils donc on les écoute quoi
aurélien refusé le plastique ou
l'aluminium pour que son bateau
d'entreprise soit partie intégrante du
paysage culturel de la loire et nous
voilà de retour à la maison de la loire
de saint-dié on est dans la salle qui
reconstitue le port de chant voir tel
qu'il était à l'époque il y a cinq cents
ans regardez il ya même léonard de vinci
et françois 1er qui nous a rejoint
tout comme vincent aldebert bonsoir
bonsoir est membre de l'association des
mariniers du port de chambord est ce
qu'il y en a beaucoup des jeunes comme
on l'a vu dans le reportage qui se lance
dans l'aventuré de la marine de loire
alors beaucoup non mais il y en a il y
en a effectivement
mais en même temps le jeune que vous
avez vu ça fait quelques années quand
même qu'il qu'il tourne sur des bateaux
alors vous aussi vincent aldebert vous
perpétuer la tradition
vous êtes mariniers et vous avez un
bateau oui on a même quatre bateaux ici
à saint dié de toue cabanée qui qui
servent en même temps à la balade et et
à l'hébergement
donc c'est des hébergements pour 4
personnes avec un confort un peu limité
mais mais il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour
pour passer une bonne une bonne nuit sur
le sur le bateau ou est-ce que vous
vient à vous cette passion pour la loire
pour la marine de loire hausse et c'est
une transmission familiale
j'avais un père qui qui naviguaient sur
la loire juste après la guerre et
c'était un parisien mais quand il est
quand quand il était dans la maison de
famille y venaient naviguer et il nous a
transmis sa et j'ai commencé par faire
beaucoup de cadeaux et des grandes
descentes de loire en campant sur les
îles
et puis et puis quand quand la marine de
loire c'est s'est re développer wahou
milieu des années 90 eh ben j'ai j'ai
embrayé quoi est lancée alors vous vous
en souvenez peut-être il y a un an ont
fêté les cinq sens au temps de la
renaissance en val de loire
pour l'occasion le château de chambord a
promené à reconstruire constituer le
transfert de cette pierre qui servait à
construire le château à l'époque sur un
une pierre de tuffeau sur un bateau de
l'homme de loi risque c'est ce genre
d'opération qui permet aussi de
perpétuer la tradition du geria là c'est
sûr c'est sûr et puis le la remontée de
la pierre l'an dernier c'était c'était
une grande expérience parce que d'abord
ça a permis de fédérer toutes les
associations entre tours et ici et
chacun a apporté sa pierre si je puis
dire à l'édifice et
moyennant quoi en fait le voyage s'est
parfaitement déroulée alors que tout le
monde prédisait que on n'arriverait
jamais à monter à remonter la pierre qui
était beaucoup plus grosse que cette
rose et surtout beaucoup plus lourdes on
s'en souvient oui merci beaucoup vincent
aldebert d'avoir fait le déplacement
jusqu'à la maison de saint dié merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis c'est la
fin de cette édition spéciale consacrée
aux 20 ans de l'inscription du val de
loire au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
on se quitte sur ces belles images de la
loire bien sûr